all right guys i was wrong i made a
video telling you guys that the apple
watt series 6
and the ipad air 4 would be released via
apple's website either today
or tomorrow and it was completely
wrong it turns out that earlier today
apple officially announced their
september event date
which is tuesday the 15th so now
the guessing game is finally over and
everything makes a whole lot more sense
and i'm gonna explain how i think
everything is gonna play out over the
next few months
now while i was wrong about there being
apple product releases this week
i was correct in saying that you
shouldn't be buying the current apple
watch right now
because we now basically have an
official announcement date
for the series 6. so let's get right
into everything we should expect
from the apple event next week as well
as the october event
next month according to mark german who
won the twitter league war against jon
prosser
by saying that we won't be seeing the
apple watch getting released this week
mark is being told that for next week's
apple event
it's going to be focused on the apple
watch and the ipad
and it won't include the iphone 12
announcement
now personally it makes more sense to me
to announce the iphone
alongside the apple watch like they've
always done but when you think about it
apple did mention during their quarterly
earnings report
that their iphones will be shipping a
few weeks later than usual
and it might seem weird to have people
wait over a month
before receiving their iphones so let's
get into what apple is very likely to
announce
on tuesday the 15th gallery rambo an ios
developer looked into the metadata for
apple's live stream event on youtube
and he found the keyword series 6 which
refers to
the new apple watch this basically
confirms that the new watch is going to
be
announced on tuesday next week so let's
quickly get into some of the features
that we should be expecting
apple should be announcing updates to
all of the apple watch's
sensors including new ones that can
potentially detect things like stress
better sleep tracking and blood oxygen
monitoring
some leaks and rumors pointed to the
bezels getting slimmed down
on the watch's display and we should
also be getting better battery life
there's also the chance that the side
button will turn into a solid state
button
like apple did for the iphone 7's home
button instead of physically clicking
we should also expect a new s6 soc
which should be faster and more
efficient than before
and the series 6 should have better
water resistance as well
it was also leaked that the series 3
watch which is 200
should be replaced by a brand new budget
apple watch
currently dubbed the apple watch se now
within the youtube metadata leak
there was also mention of the ipad and
ipad air
which have both been rumored to be
launching very soon so we should
probably also expect the ipad air 4 to
get announced on tuesday as well
so let's talk about the features we're
expecting for that this year's ipad air
is most likely going to take on the same
body
as the 11 inch ipad pro with square
edges on the sides
a flat back and rounded corners on the
display
this totally makes sense because in the
past the ipad air 3 took on the same
exact
body as the old 10.5 inch ipad pro
so we should also expect support for
apple's magic keyboard case
and the 2nd gen apple pencil now since
the iphone announcement is currently
being rumored to not happen until next
month
we can most likely expect the ipad air 4
to come
packing the a13 bionic chip and
not the a14 and compared to the ipad pro
we shouldn't be expecting all the main
features like the 120hz display
the quad speakers or the excellent
camera system
with lidar all of that stuff is being
reserved for the ipad pro
now there have also been a lot of rumors
pointing to the budget ipad being
updated as well
and i personally believe that since it's
the budget model
apple will simply update the processor
to the a12 chip
and not change much else so that means
the display size
could very likely stay at the same 10.2
inches
the price will most likely stick to the
same 329
but there is a chance that apple could
bring it down to 300
now other than that there's a chance
that apple could announce their long
rumored airpods studio
over ear headphones but they could also
save it for
next month's event i guess we'll just
have to see because everything is
all mixed up this year now let's go
ahead and talk about the iphone event
that's rumored to be coming next month
apple's gonna announce the iphone 12
lineup
but most current rumors are pointing to
the less expensive models
shipping first with the more expensive
pro models
potentially shipping way out into
november
because of delays so be aware of that a
big focus of the event will be on the
new a14 chip
built by tsmc using their brand new 5
nanometer process
so there will be a lot of talk about the
performance and the future of their
chips
apart from that apple will most likely
release their air tags
tracking product which has been rumored
for months now
and there's also the chance that we're
going to see the release of the air
power
wireless charging map now since apple is
splitting up their product announcements
into two different events this year
and they're announcing the watch and new
ipads separately from the iphone
there's a good chance that apple will
also talk about their new apple silicon
max
at the same event next month the main
reason this would make sense is if they
have a whole section
dedicated to their silicon chips with
the a14
the a14x for the ipad pro and the new
mac family of chips
and so far from all of the leaks and
rumors we should be expecting a
replacement for the macbook air
which could be priced as low as eight
hundred dollars
and a new 13-inch macbook pro with an
apple silicon chip
this is going to be a very big deal for
apple so these new macs will definitely
be announced at some sort of event
whether it's the same event as the
iphone or a completely separate event
but we'll just have to wait and see so
there you guys go
sorry if i let anybody down by saying
that the apple watch is going to be
released
this week we just gotta wait one more
week for apple's official event
and then we'll finally know for sure
what's getting announced
on tuesday the 15th so definitely click
that circle above to subscribe so you
don't miss out on our reviews and
comparison videos
of those new apple products that are
coming next week and also next month
and definitely check out that video
right there for leaks and rumors on the
apple watch series 6.
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one
[Music]